we are here in the city that never
sleeps we had Peter King stop by Taylor
rooks a part of the BR Live family with
us we'll be stopping by in studio later
on this hour with Hank Azaria joining us
Brock Meyer himself in our number three
but I turn to my right and I see two
guys who I pleased to say that I know
well and I'd love their show billions
that is now in season number four
episode number four coming up this
Sunday at 9:00 Eastern Time on Showtime
Brian Koppelman and David Levine good to
see you guys man we are now brockman I
told you earlier in the program yes that
we are gonna start this interview with
breaking news
okay breaking news here prepared for
anything on the Rich Eisen show it's
exciting breaking it I think it is
exciting breaking news who should break
this news well you want to break this
this is a huge billions casting update
and so you may think we're gonna talk
about a Robert DeNiro you might imagine
Sean Connery's gonna finally make his
comeback big time and he's gonna do it
on Showtime Hackman yeah sure we wrote a
Hackman movie so I guess it's possible
but in fact it's none of those the truth
of the matter is that Rich Eisen himself
has a cameo in season four it's already
been filmed when I left for two days in
January okay go to New York it was
because of these you are all that was
going on no it was not rehab yeah it was
definitely nice knows we have of a sword
reputation will rehab what everyone says
but you Brock Meyer thing and this
proves you can actually act yes it was
awesome you guys Wow awesome okay I
don't we're not gonna reveal let's not
talk about what it is okay you are
clothed I think it's fair to say there's
not even briefed you did a great job
thank you thank you know you came in
and it was really fun because I'll say
rich as you know you do remember if your
guys like us who do this it's real easy
to but be a fan of our show in the
fourth season but you came out early and
loudly in favor of the show yes when it
was just starting and before sort of
like this critical consensus really
happened and you reached out to us both
online early on to say like this is
great I'm loving the show and we started
going back and forth a lot online and so
when we had this thing that seemed like
it would fit I texted it and this is
what's so great right about the modern
age we've become friends online we know
a million of the same people but we had
this notion and I sent you a text and
two minutes later you were like I'm in I
must work it out I'm not gonna tell
anybody and then you came and crushed it
you entertained the crew
it was wonderful when you put on that
little USO style show and I was
surprised you had the dancing girl yes
with you and I fell in love with a show
to begin with and for anybody who for
whatever reason has yet to see it you
have to because it is a modern-day tale
that we see play out every single day
obviously we're law and versus money as
it was obviously more so in season one I
don't want to get too deep into the
weeds and into the woods here but it is
really an incredible show with a lot of
Brio with a lot of energy that comes to
it from the city and from the characters
and the way they talk to one another and
with one another and treat one another
it really is just a joy every word that
comes out of your you know I guess hands
or mouths and into the characters I mean
who is David Bryant the the who is the
inspiration for Bobby Axelrod the
billionaire played by Dana that we're
not gonna break that there's no I mean
is there somebody there there's no one
person okay you know we've we've been
fortunate to spend time with a lot of
these billionaires and you know we've
grabbed some characteristics from a
bunch of them so it's a bit of an
amalgam but it's also each of fictional
creation you know we grew up on Long
Island we saw these big businessmen
walked around like they own the world
and we were captivated by it since we
were kids and you know we saw these
these 40 year old guys with billions of
dollars who can do whatever they want
they have airplanes boats security men
they were like little nation states of
their own and we were like let's make a
show about a guy like this especially we
really really found the idea that there
were self-made you know we've all met
people who've inherited fortunes we
wanted to examine what it takes an
American now what you have to turn
yourself into what kind of ambition
fuels you right so become not somebody
who's made a nice living or not somebody
who's got a couple houses but somebody
who's worth billions of dollars and as
Dave said we were fortunate enough to
get to hang around even when we were
starting it with a couple of people like
this and then as it's gone we've met
more so there are there are billionaires
like Marc Lasry who owns the Bucks who
spent a lot of time with us talking
about it and this is after the show
after we made the pilot of the show
and so we got insight from from lads and
there were a couple of lines that he
said to us that ended up in the show
Lazar he said to us listen there are
plenty of people who can do the math
fewer people can explain it and if you
can do both you become a billionaire and
that's something that the owner of the
Bucks the owner of the box told us
because the way he built he was a hedge
fund guy who built his fortune right
that way and if you've ever been around
Marc it's amazing his ability to connect
with everybody most people who are good
at doing the structural side of that
kind of very complicated investing are
math geeks and they really have a much
harder time in listing you but Marc
Lasry could sit down and make everybody
in this room feel like his best friend
and so the characters not at all based
on Marc we'd already written it and
created it before that right but guys
like Mark Cuban's been on the show I've
seen huben has given us a lot of his
time he's he has yeah a lot of his time
over there we'll have lunch with him
once we done it once every season and
where he'll break down for us the way
he's thinking the way he believes
billionaires are thinking about the
world now and then there were people who
some VCS that we talked to to venture
capitalists who are really smart about
this world and we just try to pick up
character insights and point of view
from from these people right qapla make
a victim care yeah Brian comma David
Levine here on the Rich Eisen show
co-creators of billions also back in the
day riding rounders of which I want to
get to in a second who got Durant on the
show who got Kevin Durant on the show is
that you David yeah because we hang out
all you know next time you swing by can
you let me drop who got to I actually
don't remember how how that came to be
yeah where were we we got word that he
liked you man uh-huh oh yeah he stopped
by the season he stopped by the writers
room the season before to hang out the
rent with this yeah yeah because he like
rich climbing reached out to me is what
happened and then rich climbing reached
out to me and we were done shooting that
season and so we said come by sometimes
we just got this the other day from a
notable person who wanted to be on the
show and we said and this is the way it
happens you know for something like that
a KD thing we said we could write
something but it'd be better if we spent
an hour with Kevin I actually got a
little bit of a point of view okay no it
works when you such a writer writer you
then can like figure out like well this
is kind of how we could use the person
so then he was able to tell us stories
about people asking a certain kind of
favor and then we were able to like flow
that in for when he gave away a
something for a bar mitzvah or something
does a Bar Mitzvah message for crack out
of that secretary of the Treasury any
money a first chair or a big charity
thing yeah
did he really do that for a secretary
Department something happens all the
time yeah I'm not sure if it was for
minuchin but it was okay for somebody
somebody with the money to pay for in
fact definitely not for the secretary
probably for Todd Fritz you know on the
Dan Patrick does that for everybody so
Duran I saw Steve Tisch owner of the
Giants it was Jonathan Tisch was on both
of them okay
at different time that's right yeah Mich
brothers have been on yeah we were happy
to write for Steve Tisch that was really
fun I mean that was great because Steve
was able to let us have Giants Stadium
and the logo of the
in the background and it really that was
you know early on the second season and
that was great because I mean everything
Atlanta super amount of credibility to
the idea of act buying the team yep and
you know there was a great moment that
really gives you the billionaire
headspace where act says you know which
are the best sheets in here and he goes
like you can have anyone but you're not
getting monitored and you know that was
an ad-lib and he just that Billy and
everything flared up in the moment
you've taken that somebody wasn't really
buying his game and owner of the Giants
stay away from my team even though
you're fictional character that's like
Optima David Levine here on the Rich
Eisen show and Paul Giamatti plays Chuck
Rhodes of a brilliant legal mind from
the Southern District of New York or now
formerly of it I don't take it to week
again deep in the woods here does he
talk about his dad at all have you ever
asked him about his father the the late
Bart Giamatti you know he doesn't talk
about him off and he he loved him and
revered him but so it's not something
that he gets into and we don't we don't
drag it out of him but you know we did
have one moment where I'm in the first
season he's trying to get axe to to like
take a big penalty and they're gonna
have this settlement conference and in
the moment he says you know no sitting
on the sidelines isn't gonna be enough
lifetime ban and we thought that there
was like this amazing irony that he was
making that statement on air did you
like the way you wrote that or did he
ad-lib that or he wrote that for him and
then we just all looked at each other
and decided to do it the thing about
Bart Giamatti is that you always hear
and this is continent with who Paul is
it is Paul is like the most professional
giving artist pretty much we've ever
worked with in our lives he worked on
them in a movie called The Illusionist
about ten years before we started
billions and immediately became real
pals and he's the most prepared he and
damian lewis and maggie siff and asia
kid so and it's incredible what we have
going on the show they just show up
completely prepared and ready Paul in
particular spend so much time preparing
focusing and from the moment he walks on
set he is trying to make sure that
everybody feels like
they're on the team that they're all
playing together and he all you ever
hear about Bart Giamatti is just what an
amazing guy he was I'm sure you've heard
this like you know president of Yale
right before baseball and I've had many
people come up to me because they know
we work with Paul and tell me stories of
kindnesses that Bart Giamatti did for
them when they were students at Yale
yeah I think he was a remarkable
vesser's loved and the students love
them and that's not a common thing when
somebody's running like I mean I don't
hear that from Paul Dave said Paul
Troutman I hear that all the time people
talk about what a remarkable dude and he
died so young it's real tragedy I know
it is
and then obviously what happened with
Pete Rose it's just the names are
totally intertwined and then when I
first became a fan of Paul Giamatti as
work I'm like I wonder if that is in
fact the son of Bart Giamatti and I
looked it up and trying to get him on
this show exactly to talk about that
I've reached out to you guys on that
front but he doesn't he will no I mean
publicly you look if you're in that
position picture being play I mean what
are you gonna say you're right you can't
say either thing you can't say great he
deserves it I don't know what phase
offsprings done but it's definitely not
sideways it's not billions we could go
on and on with the filmography it's not
the same thing and then you you have
John Malkovich in the show I had no idea
he was showing up that was just a couple
of seasons ago and for fans of yours
from the rounders days that have Teddy
KGB show up as a Russian in this was
just a stroke of genius did how how did
you get him to reprise this in a way
well we became great friends with John
when we were making rounders it was our
first movie but you know we got to be
the local experts because we knew all
about Hold'em and very few people did
back then so right from the start when
he showed up we gave him the lessons and
we set him up to make sure that he
seemed like you know the smartest player
at the table and it started a friendship
that's lasted until now and we you know
we just call them and said you know we
want to press you into service can you
come do this and he made the time and
you know it was obviously amazing
we were aware that we were having John
play a Russian and we knew what people I
mean we knew that it was a great East
look we loved it little Easter eggs
sure go out the whole thing and people
have asked it's so funny
people really get carried right this
year people keep asking if he's gonna
eat Oreos on the show it's like listen
he's not in Oreos he's not eatin Hydrox
like none of that people like to say is
he the same guy is he really Teddy KGB
if he made 20 years oh no he went away
from the poker tables and suddenly roll
the no it's just a nice fun thing that
you have Malkovich doing a slightly
different Russian accent well but I
think you're also getting into what a
lot of people want to see is maybe
another rounders that has that has been
didn't we have Matt Damon on the show a
year ago was something like that Chris
like that brought it up and he said that
there was something in the ether is
there something in the ether on that
yeah but it's always just very much the
ether for some reason this has been
talked about you know we've talked about
it with Matt we've talked about if the
other actors with it with Jon Dahl who
directed the first one and he's directed
many billions episodes and it's just
something for various reasons that has a
hard time coming to fruition the rights
are owned by a sovereign wealth fund and
they like bought all of the underlying
Miramax movies and so it's a sticky
listen you have a high net worth
audience if anyone out there wants to go
acquire the rights and he mover and
shaker and then come back to us with
them we're already it sounds like an
episode of billions let's find out there
let's throw it out there yeah go get the
right clothes Matt Damon sounded like he
was totally into Matt wants to do we all
want to do we all want to do it he
totally sounded like you said yeah you
want to give me an idea of what what it
would be there would be poker okay we
would catch up with worm we catch up
with worm find out what he's up to
okay it's right to know that's good to
know good to know that just start them
to hang our hat on right yes and is
there any poker on the set of billions
anything Bob come out it's not something
that happens a lot but we had one
episode in
was it the second season yeah where
there was a third no I'm talking about
all fair well that's when it happened
because we had the whole place set up
with these twenty tables for this Wall
Street tournament right and there were
chips and they were dealers and like it
was just in the air and people were
going I mean I'll say rich that when we
made the job we have now as showrunners
it's really hard to justify also a
little dispiriting to the rest of the
crew if suddenly they saw the two of us
but they're all working so hard you know
moving equipment
yeah and we're just like who wants to
play a little card up at the ice
shaytaan you know it just feels like
wrong sort of thing when we made Ocean's
thirteen and you know we're living in a
casino yes that was built for the thing
from months yes there was a running
poker game we played poker everyday that
we shot that movie there was a poker
game and most nights
afterwards like that was a long-running
poker game and on rounders who played
all the time too but on this one because
of our position we're gonna use we're
gonna act like well modicum of
professional I'm just that one day we
had Phil Hellmuth there who did a cameo
yes episode yeah uh you know so he was
happy to sort of like make it game
happen do you remember even that day we
played this mini tournament we made the
blinds got really fast but it was during
our lunch break and then you could feel
everyone wanting like the people playing
wanted to keep it going
and I remember an assistant director
like whispering to us like yeah last one
for you last one for you um
I know who our favorite character is on
the show who do you guys hear billions
you're the most favorite character to
get into the weeds I mean you're
probably looking for wags no but no you
hear all of them
I mean wags seems to have in New York a
real cult following cuz all these guys
think he's a good guy and think they
should act like it right but that's here
in New York mostly we hear all the
characters like well but for us it's
it's again we we Chris Brock Renard we
love the show and we'd every word but
when Chuck Rhodes dad shows up on screen
actually you met Chuck senior every word
out of his mouth is like all right it's
like cotton
yeah it really is you know we have table
reads before each episode right but we
can hear the script but it's really the
whole cast assembled yes it's the only
time that the whole cast is together and
we do the thing and people don't do
rehearse prepared versions of the of the
thing they just read it you know it's
like at lunch hour we just want to hear
it
but when Chuck senior Jeff Daman the
actor plays him does his scenes
literally everybody just like drops what
they're doing is amazing every word out
of the guy's mouth is hypnotic the only
the only the only character we can
equate that with in recent years was
sterling from Roger Sterling from Mad
Men what an honor that's like our
favorite show ever you know let me just
say that if you like Chuck senior you're
really gonna like some stuff that's
coming up things that we everytime we
get the notes back and they don't say
take that line out we can't believe I'm
also super into dollar bill like
something about that guy like his well
if you like dollar bill wait till you
see my oh if I may drop drop it's a
whole loaf he's saying this week it was
amazing Brian Koppelman and David Levine
check out billions every single Sunday
night at 9:00 Eastern Time it is
fantastic big fans of you guys
personally professionally and I'm thank
you for coming on this show this is
great thank you Taylor rooks of bleacher
report when we come back the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience